[Music]
stranger things meets Terminator at
Netflix's to Doom event an exciting
addition to the cast of The Fifth and
final season was announced especially
fans of the old movies of The Terminator
franchise could be particularly excited
about this the announcement came from
Arnold Schwarzenegger who is Netflix's
Chief action officer during the annual
to Doom event Schwarzenegger revealed
that a long time Terminator co-star
Linda Hamilton will be part of the
upcoming final season of stranger things
in a video message she shared her
enthusiasm and anticipation for the new
role however the details about
Hamilton's character remain top secret
and have not been elaborated on filming
on the final season of stranger things
was originally scheduled to begin these
days but it has been delayed due to The
Sensational writer strike work on the
scripts for The Fifth Season began back
in August of last year and is believed
to be mostly complete it was by the way
decided by the showrunners and executive
producers Matt and Ross Duffer to
postpone the production instead of
shooting without the writers on the set
as a result of these delays the start of
filming and streaming of the final
episodes of stranger things remains
uncertain it is expected that the
kickoff of the final season will not
happen before 2024 but we will of course
keep all fans updated in the coming
months
foreign
[Music]